this lecture will be on the candidates
tournament which is ongoing
because Marlar told me so and this is in
your favorite city cantonments East
which is in Siberia your favorite place
whoever wins this tournament plays the
World Championship in November against
Magnus Carlsen probably Anand again and
unfortunately when things happen in
Europe and Asia we get to stay up all
night and watch them this was the only
night maybe the tournament where I
actually slept and didn't watch the
games live so I'm actually sort of wake
now I've been doing a lot of chess work
on no sleep because I want to watch the
games live and they start 4:00 in the
morning our time 3:00 in the afternoon
and continue on Sisk so there's eight
players and before the tournament nobody
gave several of them a chance to win
Fiddler Anand ma McGovern on Drake and
were considered just fillers to see who
would actually win the tournament
probably 90% of people thought it would
be Aronian or kramnik and yes or sara
one who also does a lot of lecturing
here thought that Topalov had some
chance okay well everybody still has a
chance I guess except and drinking and
karaoke so these are the best players in
the world some people are upset that
Nakamura is not playing especially
people in the US and some are upset that
Cara Wan is not playing and many people
I think are upset griffix not playing
because the organisers had to give one
wild card out if the tournament was in
this chess club it would have been
Nakamura but it was in Russia so they
figured they give it to a Russian player
make sense and people thought it would
be Greece shook but it was Ziggler
silver was good too okay so for some
reason anons playing well this
tournament and I haven't said that
sentence in about four years maybe
longer
I don't know why I was playing well I
just know that he's playing well now
obviously he's in first place I'm not
talking about that you could be the
first place to not play well that's what
I do for a living
okay first place is not playing well I
got all that but I was actually playing
well in fact the guy who likes to diss
everybody I hope you're watching this
the guy living fun of now your mullinski
your belinskiy likes to say everybody's
the worst player ever
he said anons made no mistakes this term
he said that today so that's high praise
from your Malinsky okay that he said it
ons playing great and anons playing
great what are you going to do will he
continue to play great Spencer does not
think so
okay because Anand has played bad for
like two years in a row so he's 44 young
very very young very oh yeah three
months younger than me okay now in round
one Aronian lost to Anand and Aronian
has the mo of losing around one that's
how he rolls okay actually top off used
to do that then top-level in the last
five games ah and Aronian lost the first
round here in the Sinquefield Cup to
Nakamura ver and dead drum position
decided to blunder okay thought there's
a good time to blunder
okay so Anand who hasn't won a rated
game in about six years now I'm half
kidding three years that's half kidding
he played white and they played one of
these real Lopez's that Aronian likes to
play now Aronian likes to play the
marshall gambit and that's where you
sacrifice upon and then you draw so
that's he likes to do that and maybe in
the last ten years he's lost one
marshall gambit most super GM's believe
the marshall gambit is fine black is
equal so they'll play what are called
anti marshall gambit so that that
doesn't happen okay which is what
happens here and now black is going to
play d5 next move which is the marshall
gambit and a non played h3 normally
white plays c3 and then d 5 is the
marshall gambit and in many variations
Aronian who's the world's leading
authority I would say unless Spencer
disagrees agree knows 25 or 30 moves a
theory and then it reads to a draw
Justin there's nothing wrong with a 4 a
4 is a very good move
there's many moves white can play to
avoid the Marshall gambit and I would
say probably 75% of super GMs avoid the
Marshall gambit because they think it'll
just be a force draw based on the
analysis that's been done so a non
playing h3 and Aronian still plays a
gambit he plays d5 he's like I'm playing
a game I don't care what you do okay
well obviously if white plays c3 to play
d4 it's hard to play Knight c3 you can't
take your own pawn so now that there's
no pawn on c3 White's light has c3
available and white didn't lose a tempo
playing c3 because so woah Aronian does
this a lot
plays these variations of you sacrifice
upon an on doesn't take the pawn but
Aronian insists so when you insist
instead of non develops a piece and he's
like all right I'll take the pawn
because you're not defending it ok and
black supposedly has good compensation
because black has good pieces
White's rook is sort of stupid because
we're going to attack it and whites
Queen side pieces haven't moved yet and
well Bishop on b7 obviously is know
pretty good dish'
okay so Rick goes back to e1 so that
black doesn't attack it and rook to e8
which is I find it a bit strange
we've got f8 looks a little funny to me
now I have three and this is I think if
I remember the game correctly although
it was 5 in the mornings maybe I forgot
it this is where Rania played his first
strange move unless it was later in the
game that I apologize not was later
Bishop d6 rookie 7 h6 i here i think
black has pretty reasonable compensation
for a pawn
but I ate six isn't doesn't seem like
the right move I mean black is down upon
yeah and now Anand unlike the previous
several years played really well okay I
haven't seen him play well in a long
time now there's a member of our club
who I won't mention Jacob and Jacob said
and I don't know this is true but it was
true today and yesterday he said it
before that he said not only is it non
playing well anons playing fast like he
used to because now a non plays slow and
bad he must have got lessons for me
again but he used to play instantly anon
was the fastest player in the world and
when he was between the ages of 15 and
25 he would use 10 20 minutes for a
whole game even in slow chess and he
would calculate lots of variations
anyhow again and now he plays as slow as
possible he trades all the pieces and
offers a draw and loses that's what he
does now but this tournament he's
decided to play fast and win
that's better decision I think on his
part and he played 95 a really really
nice move so he's giving back the pawn
but he gets rid of all of blacks play
and he does the most important thing in
any grandmasters repertoire what does
the move 95 do that every grandmaster
wants to do I know Spencer knows anybody
else no trans bishops grandmasters
overvalue bishops we love bishops I
didn't like bishops then I got this
paper from feeted that says I was a
grandmaster
I love bishops Wow bishops are great
okay now flack wants to win his pawn
back and not let this Knight sit on e5
be Kevin Knight 75 you have to take it
and trade everything off and white has
an advantage because white has two
bishops is it a winning advantage
probably not but you know white has two
bishops and black has nothing for the
two bishops now when you have two
bishops which you probably don't have
except for Ken West because it's a
grandmaster thing uh
most you should have got that you one of
your bishops has no counterpart this
Bishop on b3 is on a white square as is
the bishop on b7 also on a white square
the bishop on e3 see I can do the others
green is on a dark square so that means
black is going to have trouble on the
dark squares White has a dark square
Bishop and black doesn't also blacks
made some pawn moves over here
okay so White's going to try to attack
those Rick d1 threatening the knight a
Rodian didn't see it and lost his knight
now now that didn't happen play Knight
f6 c4 and he's hoping that this will
this trade will happen and then black
will have two isolated pawns is that
what happened no ridiculous so black
played c6 and white was very insistent
and played a4 white said could you take
one of those to have two isolated pawns
the thing is as you know with bishops
you want the open position so Anan wants
to trade those pawns again an open
position for his rooks and for his
bishops and black also wants those pawns
gone because this bishop is very
suspicious blocked by all these pawns on
the other hand black doesn't want to
have two isolated pawns now why did it
on place for other than to trade
well black was going to put his light on
the really nice d5 square that would be
very risky I wouldn't recommend that
so Aronian has a tough position here
because white has two bishops for
nothing so White's just come of his
bishops around and blacks going to try
to draw so he eventually took so his
Knight has the d5 square but two
isolated pawns not good Bishop c5 did
you think
anam was going to let it Rodian take now
look there f3 the rook has to move King
F to Bishop c8
now the Gypsy it's my kind of move first
of all I like retreating second of all
that bishops
not good on b7 it's blocked by two pawns
reminded me of the game fine gold Roper
when Mario played Bishop b7 behind that
c6 pawn okay
it was reminded of it because I won but
okay Bishop CA now that this was going
to relocate to a better diagonal Bishop
f1 my favorite move in chess which you
all know even all of you know on the on
YouTube because the bishop is blocked
the route can't move up and black might
take this bishop if White's not careful
after Bishop f1 Black's not going to
take that bishop and the bishop controls
the whole diagonal but it doesn't block
either white rook that's why I liked it
with bishop f1 it defends the Kings side
it attacks the whole diagonal and the
white rooks aren't blocked and you may
have noticed there was an x-ray attack
on this bishop the rook might take the
bishop later
well now the Rickon c1 is defending the
bishop so anon he's pretty good Anand
rookie six defending this week's e6 pawn
rook to d3 and the problem is why can
attack the a6 pawn and the c6 pawn and
I'm not sure what black is going to do
what's black going to attack I was black
going to get active counter play well he
couldn't Knight f4 that looks pretty
active rip b3 the rooks coming to b6 rip
d8 this works coming to d2 you think I
not let that happen so say no no okay so
also I don't remember what he did but I
still know one of the things super
grandmasters do well is they figure out
what their opponent wants to do then
they don't let them do it okay a famous
world champion I'm sure he's your
favorite from the 1960s was well known
for this which will champion prevents it
all of your counter play before you knew
you had it 60s what who that's my son
yes
okay Tigran Fisher would have been 70s
yeah but yeah Patricia Chiana was world
champion in the 60s and he stopped all
counterplay unfortunately he had too
many drawers too many Italy one is too
many
Bishop III stopping Rick d2 now Rick
teach is very risky and attacking the
knight Knight to g5 did white give up
his bishop on e3 doesn't want the two
bishops anymore not to bishops this ship
d2 and again I don't know what what
black does here black waits to lose his
pawns he's going to wait Knight f6 now
90 of sixes are treating move so that
would excite can West Kenwood say my
opponents retreating I'm going to go
attack okay and then he would say oh my
do ships attacked yeah like he just said
now because the night I'm g5 was
blocking the rook and he moved it out of
the way so this retreat was actually an
offensive move and an on took offense to
that this ship a5 saving the bishop
attack in the rook and blacks Queen
sides a goner
now Aronian is pretty good so he doesn't
lose easily rocket axe the bishop Knight
d5 attacks the rook now an on played
Bishop takes e5 after the game he said I
should have played rook takes c6
although not sure if computers agree
with that I think computers think he
played the right move Knight takes rook
the bishop on e5 is hanging Bishop to d4
go to played rook takes c6 here and now
there's a nice juicy pawn on a4 hanging
right yummy see the pawn black intake
but unfortunately then your Knights a
little iffy you might lose your knight
then you won't do well on the other hand
if you lose this pawn for nothing and
then this pawn is attacked you might
lose too so it looks like black shits
going to lose he did take the pawn white
took the pawn
text the bishop and he attacks so the
Bishop's defended the knight is trapped
the knight is attacked
what did black do did not resign Aronian
is too good
he's on later how do we save our knight
protected good answer Bishop d7
unfortunately that Knight can't move to
a lot of squares zero would be the right
number of squares otherwise you get
captured b3 hmm
what do we do
well Aronian is better than you okay
unless hi Magnus otherwise roading is
better than you okay
if Magnus is watching I apologize to
Magnus he probably is watching right
okay and he plays triki triki triki to
save his night okay he's a tricky guy he
plays Bishop b5 now if you want to get
two pieces for a rock by taking the
bishop you're not going to get two
pieces for a rock because this rooks
attacking your bishop also so you're
going to take the rules you're going to
lose so he played rook to b4 and now the
move you all would play Knight to be too
because Aronian saw if Bishop takes
Knight rip D to check wins the bishop
back on the other hand that Knights not
so good on b2 what's the only square the
knight on b2 can go to that's safe d1
that wasn't my answer but that was
better than my answer very good night d3
is also possible but your move was
better so an on took and played King to
e3 to go take the knight now Bishop
takes Knight is a threat
pretty good threat check pins the bishop
King c3 and now Aronian resigned because
the only move is night d1 and that's the
end of your night I hate when that
happens
so the two bishops won the game but only
after non-traded bishops to trap that
night on this
side of the board now that game shocked
everybody
and that's why Spencer left he's
probably really angry because I think
Sudan has a zero percent chance of
winning it's at least 0.1% at least and
before the tournament nobody thought of
non could win and I was like I talked to
a nun's wife he's like nah he can't win
terribly okay so it's 14 rounds and
we've played six and the next round is
not tonight because there's a rest day
so and if you're watching at home you're
totally baffled cuz tournaments over
already
yeah exactly exactly
okay so of the first six rounds this is
the only decisive game the black one
Anand was black played sort of fastest
game and lets you know the in this
opening Dimitri what's the name of this
opening it's like how some a close
enough now let's see it the right answer
the Slav right okay so we got some we
got some slob going on and Mahmoud grf
plays Queen c2 I've actually had this
position with with both colors not at
the same time
well maybe okay and there's lots of
things black can do and I'm sure that
Anand looked at this for his match very
unlikely would happen because Carlson's
never played Queen c2 in the Slav but
you might so you look at everything and
a non played Bishop g4 which is sort of
a new kind of move twenty years ago ten
years ago everybody played Bishop f5
here but Bishop g4 is becoming more
popular I don't know if I nons had this
position before but I have to look at
Bishop g4 because I have somebody
playing against me and I didn't know
anything so ok Knight be d2 and mom and
you're off likes to play unusual stuff
and get his opponent out of prep that's
hard to do with an on because the noms
been prepping for months for his match
so an odd knows a lot of theory and
everything and their game was pretty
boring nothing much happened which is
typical of this system a lot of slobs
are boring and trade some pieces and
nothing happens ok man it's a joke I
make every lecture I forgot it
hang on there for a few hours
Blair Witch Project that's the joke okay
I'm done you know nothing happens
nothing happens nothing happens it's
over
that's a Blair Witch Project okay so
nothing happens then a pretty boring
game and King eh eh well he played King
Akshay with black in another game like
tha it so a non wants to move his f-22
the f5 or f6 but he didn't do so in this
position why ken west because it would
be illegal and he doesn't like the fact
that these were on the same diagonal
which means this pawn is not moving
occasionally this Bishop on h5 gets
trapped white plays g4 + f5 you're like
oh my gosh up strap so King h8 now this
pawn can move and this bishop can go to
xf7 and attack White's pieces 'if I've
typical mob Adyar of aggressive player
rikiei attacking the pawn f4 defending
the pawn and f6 now that white pawns
attacked a lot now a lot of you are
looking at this position and wondering
if this is to connect for lecture
incorrect okay this is a back I mean
chest lecture so white has this
beautiful pawn chain wise playing very
aggressively and you all like white okay
except you know and on one of the games
you're confused now it's true that I
like white and I like that pawn
structure and I agree with everything I
said which is sort of normal however
when you move all the plums in front of
your king there's no pawns in front of
your King unless you're playing bughouse
and you get some put some pawns in front
of your King so for the next however
long the game lasts which isn't long
White has no pawns in front of his king
his King is exposed and when you push
pawns in front of your king and your
opponent puts a rook on the seventh rank
your King's gonna be on the back rank
for the next 80 moves and you'll get
mated so white has to be careful that
his own King doesn't get exposed later
in the game which he was not careful
about
so he traded and again sort of boring
everything's equal equal pawns
you know nobody both sides have two
bishops in the night both sides haven't
moved their Queen rook yet Bishop f3
which I don't like because it gets rid
of one of White's defenders in front of
his King but maybe he wanted that Bishop
gone because he was afraid this Bishop
was going to be a monster okay but I
don't like Bishop f3 rookie for that's
the aggressive Anand from 25 years ago
would that guy go now if black could
place c5 white may not like that right
Ken yeah so rookie three trade more
pieces Queenie and Queen yet I think is
the best move of the game second best
one tied for first yeah so Queenie it
attacks the bishop which everybody sees
and it also prepares to play Queen h5
where the Queen's very active Knight g4
checkmate so Queenie states a lot better
than Queen e7 because we can now shift
to the Kings side now Mahmud yarv is not
my student I'm not sure why maybe
because he's 300 points higher rated
than me maybe okay but probably not and
if he was my student I would be yelling
at him and he would say I don't speak
English but still I would really speaks
English okay actually if you watch the
live commentary and all the stuff he
doesn't speak English but he does he's
just pretending he doesn't I've heard
him speak English I'm drinking is the
same I'm drinking doesn't speak English
unless he wants to on the other hand you
can't stop swindler from speaking
English or anything so they're talks
non-stop forever in any language but
Andrei Kedah Mamadou of pretend they
don't speak English but they do okay so
I would be yelling at mounted jar of I
might have to learn Russian yell Adam
but I would because he pushed all the
puns in front of his king and they're on
dark squares right I can prove it see
and he got rid of his white square
bishop and I tell my students don't do
that he's not my student so he did that
and you might think what's wrong with
that while you're going to see what's
wrong with that you get checkmated
because you can't protect any of those
squares so if he was a good player any
good player in this position would play
f4 deaf to any good any good player
would play that if he asked her was you
he would nod yeah that's right but they
don't let you do that
okay but if he was allowed to do that
that would be the best move you got to
move those pawns back and make your King
safe okay but he played Bishop b6 to
make sure his Bishop was offsides good
for getting checkmated queen h5 bishop
to d4 rook e8 well if the rook goes to
e2 and the Queen goes to f3 or h2 I
don't think White's game is so good
notice how all of whites pieces are on
the Queen side and his King is on the
Kings side exposed not so good also
wrong move 95 and the rook is still on
a1 how many of them think it's moving on
you 5 a fool any of them maybe yeah
maybe now let's move 25 or so but rooks
on a1 not participating in the game and
an on is starting to attack the King
rook F 1 now if you play rookie to all
play rook F to Knight g4 threatening me
but mama drives 2757 so he saw that so
he played Queen c2 defending me and
stopping rookie to c5 that's probably
the best move of the game because now
White's queen is overworked and
overloaded and so is the bishop so some
of you may have noticed that 93 forks
the Queen and the rook right but then
why it's going to take it and the reason
93 forks
the reason 93 forks the king and the
rook the Queen in the rook is because
white played f4 I said you should put
back to have two but nobody listens so
that weakens the e3 squared nothing's
protecting e3 well after C
five if the bishop moves away we'll play
93
if the bishop goes to f2 what do you
think ken west Bishop f2 defends defend
XIII right it does but now Queen age to
mate again so Mahmud yah Robson hmm I'll
guess I'll take that pawn rook c8
pinning the Knights of the Queen ah not
nice if you're white yeah that's not so
good so all of whites pieces are pinned
and attacked and Queen h2 mate the Queen
on c2 is overworked
if only white could play pawns back to
f2 and so rugby one because Mahmud job
is really tricky he's hoping for lots of
captures on c5 and he'll play rook d8
mate at the appropriate moment okay and
Anand didn't want to get made it because
he wants to be world champion again okay
if you don't want to get mated what do
you do in this position your kings on h8
I want to get mated you want to get
mated John yeah eight six yeah this ship
takes an eight-six yeah I think he could
play h6 right away but yeah now he won't
get made it because there's left so now
blacks threatening Queen takes bishop
Shak trade Queen's and whites up Black's
up a knight if he did that earlier Rick
g8 mate would have been annoying king h1
and the idea of king h1 is very sneaky
and some of you would blunder here and
lose an on didn't blunder in lose
because after king h1 Mahmoud you have
realized that black has 800 winning
moves so he resigned again however the
most obvious winning move does not win
however some less obvious moves
incredibly win and when Mama drop saw
those he resigned before Don could move
so for example 9f to check is very
annoying because white loses all of his
pieces losing all of your pieces is bad
because if you take it
the Queen there's queen takes rook check
and then there's Queen d5 check anything
with your Bishop 93 also wins
immediately there's no move however when
he played King h1 he had an idea then he
resigned but he had an idea
his idea was well okay if if rook takes
rook d8 mate if Queen takes what is
white play rook da track and then why
it's pretty good good winning chances
probably winning
only illegal move well Queen - I didn't
see that it's so bad I wouldn't call it
legal and then Queen takes Queen so
that's what mama Goff was thinking when
he played king h1 then he's like oh wait
a minute all these other moves went
immediately
I guess I'd resigned okay and that's the
only game black one and that was like
old school Anand played fast attacked
his opponent his opponent weakened his
King and Anan beat'em and those were it
nons only two wins of the tournament but
that's enough to be in clear first
because most players rated 27 2800 don't
lose a lot they lose rarely now this was
a very strange game and this was played
today yeah it's tomorrow in Russia now
but we'll say today this game was played
today and this is fiddler versus Mahmoud
yar of Mahmud Rob's white Spindler
played the Dutch okay if there's two
openings I hate its openings that don't
like other cultures and the Dutch okay
right you see what I'm saying now the
Dutch has been doing well at the top
level lately especially if you're
playing Aronian because the ronia plays
like the worst line against it I hope
you're watching this live on fiddler
doesn't play the Dutch let's see who has
a lot of acumen regarding the world top
players in this room what is fiddler
known for with black raise your hand if
you know against d4 Fiddler's the
world's leading authority on one opening
it's not the Dutch no there's less
acumen that I saw it nothing you got
nothing for me strands nothing ah
I've never been so disappointed I'm just
going to leave because Perry is in that
room the answer is the grünfeld and and
fiddler plays the groove of a lot in
fact you played this tournament okay so
similar plays Grunfeld every game with
black and wins every game and they know
he's going to apply it and you still win
that's pretty good so you play the Dutch
which they did know he was going to play
because he doesn't do that okay so the
psychological warfare has started okay
and they played sort of a mainlined
Leningrad Dutch okay normal stuff
probably the two best players in the
world who played the Dutch a lot are
both American Hikaru Nakamura and got a
con ski and Nakamura plays it more than
calm ski does makovski plays it
occasionally
okay the Dutch is a very uncompromising
opening it means I want to win I don't
want to equalize and draw I want the
game to be exciting and you blunder and
I win swindler has to win because
Mahmoud jarv and this event is one of
the weaker players at 2757 fidei so he's
like I got to beat this guy this guy's
no good and I mean if you don't win
you're not going to win the tournament
now some of you might think well wait a
minute
swindlers lucky to get in this
tournament if he comes in third that
would be a great success because he
should come in like seventh or sixth if
he comes in second that would be a great
success well actually there's only one
success to this tournament first okay
otherwise you're not going to be happy
if you come in first you're going to
play Carlsen for a world championship in
November and if you lose that match what
you will you'll get a million dollars so
I recommend winning this tournament
that's I recommend it if you're watching
the windows tournament yeah so swindler
has to win the tournament so he has to
take some risks if he plays his usual
solid self and drawers of black and
tries to win a game or two with white
and gets a fantastic plus to score and
comes in second and he gets second place
but if he starts winning games because
he's mixing it up then he might be the
world champion so you can't you can't
try to draw your games now the opposite
approach is being taken by Sergey
Karjakin
okay a very suspicious approach Targa
actually one of the youngest players of
the tournament he's the same age as on
Drake and they're both 24 they're born a
month apart look on the prep I did for
this lecture now I just sort of knew
that and
kuryakin draw draw draw ROG around these
doing the tournament and somehow this
doesn't work mathematically by drawing
every game he's in seventh out of eight
he didn't drive a game he lost one then
he'd be fine so he had one lost in five
draws he's in seventh out of eight he's
not going to win the tournament
okay so drawing all your games you don't
win the tournament you've got to win the
tournament so Fiddler's playing a little
unusual
obviously he prepared this line now I
heard a rumor on the internet so it's
obviously true that Spindler has three
seconds with him at this tournament so
Spindler wants to win this tournament
because we can become a millionaire one
tournament now winning the World
Championship is also good you probably
didn't think so
but when you win the World Championship
then you play for more championship
again another million-dollar payday so
potentially is fiddler wins this
tournament could be worth millions not
just 1 million but you never know so
take some risk to when the tournament's
a good idea and some people believe we
call them smart people that if you play
poker you should do this because if you
come seven to the poker tournament the
guy who came in first got more money
than you when I say more I mean a lot
more so if you came in seventh ten
tournaments in a row the guy who came
first once and lasted there six times
got more money than you okay in fact
maybe a hundred times so coming in first
is very important in a lot of poker
tournaments and in chess tournaments
it's not except for this one if I
playing the st. Louis Open then I come
in second instead of first it's 400
bucks this might be a million two
million so you better come in first
so Spindler is not kidding around he's
like I got to win this game okay Queenie
it's a popular move now black wants to
play e5 white place for Queen side
expansion and black plays ephod because
I said
as if you didn't do that what it looks
silly and Wow Coria the computers the
game was about equal both sides that
what they were supposed to do got the
pieces out castle gained some space
attacking the pawn on e4 and you know
the game was pretty reasonable and at
some point in the game the computer
liked black it's a black student grade
because white has 37 isolated pawns
which is the world's record gay Black
has one isolated pawn so normally when I
see a bishop and a queen on the same
diagonal
I like the bishop because when those
pieces are traded it's working out good
for the bishop so black has a good
position here Black's equalized he got
out of Mahmud guards preparation
probably for the Grunfeld and he has
good wing chances and they played and
material was even or white was a pawn up
B Phi was a fantastic move you can't
take with the Queen because after a
queen shred your bishop is hanging you
can't take with a pawn even ken west
agrees pawn shakes is very risky
what's a bishop on e6 so he played Queen
e3 breaking the pen
he took the pawn my computer says Bishop
takes c4 is a big advantage for black so
if you ask you why did he play B takes I
don't know not a good move but okay
still his positions fine and this is
also okay yeah
now fiddler went totally crazy and when
they asked him in the press conference
why did you go totally cos I went
totally crazy
so this positions about equal equal
material equal everybody is the same
pieces of Queen rook and two bishops and
he played a move that makes zero sense
and I can't I and Fabiano Cara wanna who
almost played in this event he was on
Twitter he was all atwitter and he was
like what is this what kind of this like
this is the worst one I've ever seen so
I don't think he liked this move and
there's no explanation for it sometimes
you hang a piece you guys know what I'm
talking about right yeah and kind of
West disagrees he says sometimes again
but this one I don't I don't I don't get
it
he played h6 notice how that hangs the
g6 pawn and you get mated so somebody
thought maybe he thought his rook was
defending it through his Bishop I don't
know about that
so the pawns defended and he undefended
it don't do that okay well you're one of
the top 10 players in the world playing
for a championship
don't make one move blunders now they
were making fun of an ond we use playing
Carlsen what a terrible player and
playing losing all his games and never
wins and all that these are the best
players in the world they make it move
like h6 and I'm doesn't do that so here
it's about equal and at your age six
that's reasonable and I don't know why
he played I don't know why you would
allow Bishop takes g6 unless you were
you know a low rated player you missed
it not if you're twenty seven fifty and
I think he's seven times Russian
champion not by playing age six he may
only be three-time of that if you did
that right John okay so now why it's
completely winning so that was a
turnaround now when I give chess lessons
brought to my chest students I talked a
lot a lot about one move blunders most
of my students are like you teach me the
night off and can you show me this
endgame that's a drop I don't know how
to draw it this you shouldn't have
anyway Bishop at night I'm like look I
see you guys play and you like hanging a
piece like stop doing that okay all the
other stuff doesn't matter now these
guys never blunder so we're like totally
shocked and he was like I don't know so
there's like haha so not only did he
hang a pawn that was kings in a lot of
trouble so that wasn't good
okay so Bishop d5 now he's tacking the
Bishop h5 cementing the bishop on g6
just what black wants and now the Queen
can't leave c8 because White's going to
meet him on the back row so the Queen's
stuck on the back row Queen d7 Bishop d4
the bishop that's defending the black
King and Bishop f7 check is double ax
clam he's winning anyway but this is a
beautiful way to win and the reason it's
beautiful isn't because that move is
good the final move of the game is a
masterpiece
so Mahmud Yahoo is having a bad
tournament looked at his opponents that
excuse me I'm having a bad tournament
but look at my reading I can play good
moves too just not this tournament but
and the reminded me there was an NBA
game played two days ago Indiana versus
Indiana's opponents came over their
opponent Lincoln was Philadelphia and
Paul George was having a bad game which
is unusual at the end of the game he
jumped over 20 people and dunked like 10
feet away and he's like I had a bad game
but I can still play good okay
so Wow mama girls having a bad
tournament he had a worse position with
white but he's like I'm not majora I can
still crush you
okay so we weren't watching the games
live we make fun of the guys who were in
last who aren't winning any games as
long as we don't play them then we can
make fun of them when they're here we're
very respectful but when they're
thousands of miles away and can't hear
us we're like Marlin yards no good and
drinkin's no good because those are the
guys coming in last but somebody's got
coming last vision of sevens fantastic
what did black do there's only one move
Queen f7 otherwise White's going to take
all your pieces and now black only has
one move rook takes Queen then black
only has one move okay
in this position well both rooks are
hanging and obviously colored bishops
and whites upon an OP of what this looks
like it might be a draw like as usually
Bishop endings of opposite colors or
draws where there's no pawns left this
game went one more move and black
resigned like didn't get to move anymore
what's that we're queer
it's funny on the internet everybody
shouted this move because their answers
running in the background my computer
says this but obviously when mama JA
replied Bishop f7 he saw he already saw
the final position this is a move Ken
Wes would not play either guarantee also
I wouldn't play it unless it was this
exact position then I would play it cuz
I know the answer I would think in a
tournament game I wouldn't find this
room that would be my guess too hard but
not only did he find it he found it a
long time ago when he played Bishop f7
it's the only move the computer likes so
all the internet guy saw it because they
had their engines running
well rook takes pawn on c7 black has a
choice of g3 or e2 probably that's the
draw because black has a nice position
Rick and Bishop are good pass pawn
tacking how many pass pawns
does white have out of these two how
many of those are passed say zero that's
the right answer still didn't say zero
terrible that's the internet like at
home like zero they're yelling into
their TV yeah zero well if that h6 pawn
was gone
like disappeared I can do that then then
it would be two very good yeah I played
rook g5 now rook takes pawn check is
risky because there's a rook there right
and whites threatening rook takes Bishop
and Bishop takes rook so what would
black play what's the obvious move I'm
helping you here take the rock right
well he resigned instead but take the
rook
yeah now we got a pass pot over here and
we got a pass pond over here and this
one's hanging so you Paul I should go
here right yeah and these ones aren't so
good
the bishop just blocks them so white
actually has three pass spawns a pawn a
pawn H pawn
I don't think blacks King can go to
three places so White's King walks up
the board and escorts one of the pawns
home is are these two pawns going to
Queen I don't think so
yeah and white just pushes all this pawn
so instead of that he gave up then Rick
g5 I think was the only winning move but
it gets rid of the jeep on so now black
white has the past H pawn this is
actually very important
the bishop controls the queening square
of the H pawn
so that means black should probably
stick around there but I don't know he
just stopped the e pawn in the a pawn
so Fiddler's gave up which was the
correct thing to do at this level that
sure would not be correct okay he
probably would if you were black but
that was a beautiful game at the end in
the middle when Spitler played h6
everybody was confused and what's funny
about that is you could say well
Stifler's having a bad tournament so he
made a bad move he wasn't having
adventures had a great tournament on the
other hand mama Gough was getting killed
and now he's having a tournament so
things are going to turn around for
these guys they're all so good that
winning one or two games in a row
especially one in a row that's a lot
then they could turn the tournament
around so far
khari Akkad and Andre can have one zero
in a row so yeah they got a win more
than that